What answer did you think about, David?
>> So this is a tiny bit different
than the one we saw earlier.
Earlier, we saw this exercise
without the square as an option, so
we were forced to pick the triangle.
But here, since we actually have the
square as the option, I think the easier
transformation is to say that
the middle shape is disappearing.
Thus, the triangle disappears and
leaves us with just that square.
So, I'd say that five
is the correct answer.
>> That's a good answer, David,
but note that three could also be
an answer because one could imagine
the relationship between A and
B a little differently.
Suppose we were to say that
the outer circle is disappearing and
the inner circle is expanding.
In that case, we will again get B.
So in that case, we might say that
the outer image is disappearing,
this square, and the inner shape
is expanding to give us three.
So three is also a legitimate answer.
>> So I imagine though,
that most people would choose
answer five over answer three.
But why would most of us choose
answer five over answer three?
>> That's a great question.
Let's look at this in more detail.